[Music]
brevity is the soul of wit after quarter
of strategic communications'
and many coats like this we all
understand the importance of being
concise but how many of you feel truly
confident that you can be as precise and
as succinct as you like to be raise your
hands
good so that means that room for our
presentation so this is a little survey
that we did of the class based on a
papers you've submitted so as you can
see many of us are still using more
words than we like so why is it so
difficult to be concise in Joseph
McCormick's book brief he identifies
five capital sins that hinders us from
being as concise as we like to be and as
I enact five of these sorry as I enact
these with Bryan and which I would
invite you to think about whether any of
these apply to you so the first is
confidence I know the materials so well
I can talk about it for days save us
some time
and don't the next this colleges I'm
just so afraid there's so many
perspectives out there please
take a stand and tell us what you really
think comfort the sound of my voice so
soothing
do you have the discipline to press the
stop button next confusion we despair
with me I have to just think about this
for a while well your mind is a mess do
you really have to share it with us
complication this is a complex topic you
can't describe it easily but it's your
job to make it simple for us so um sorry
so basically take a moment and see if
you identify with any of the five
capital sins that we just enacted if you
do then the first step you can take to
its concession is to change your mindset
so what we're gonna do next is to give
you some concrete tools that you can
practice to make your sentences shorter
more clear and more powerful and these
are things that you can do immediately
today after you leave the room so that
it becomes a daily habit to make your
communication more compelling Rebecca
will first start with structure which is
about where you're going with your
communication and why before rich and
Brian will share on language and how you
get there let's start with the Prince of
pithy statements the Cheshire Cat what
would you tell me please where I ought
to go from here that depends a lot of
where you want to get to I don't much
care where then it doesn't matter which
way you go
that's the Cheshire Cat teaches us if we
don't know our destination then it's
hard to get there if we don't know our
structure and our communication it's
hard to be concise structure is
important it helps you share everything
you want to share but nothing more I'll
share three tools to help you structure
for concision the first one is the brief
map the next two our companion tools
headlines and why why why the brief map
helps you prepare to be concise by
focusing on the most important ideas you
need to share that way you're able to
combat the confusion
the B stands for background what context
do you need to establish the R is
relevant what is the reason that you are
sharing this I'll dive more into R with
the yyy tool the AI is information what
are the key ideas you need to pass on
the e is ending how will you conclude
and the S is follow-up what questions
might be asked what questions do you
need to ask the good news with brief is
that it's simple you can jot it on a
piece of paper right before you're about
to walk in to an important conversation
and that way you're structured for
confession let's try an example JD I
know I've missed class every Friday this
quarter and this is important because
you and I both care about my learning
the thing is I've had a doctor's
appointment every Friday in Tahoe I
would like to have these absences
excused do you need a doctor's note
breathe in this situation helps me
prepare for a conversation that was a
little bit scary and make sure I shared
just the right amount of information and
got a clear response even if not the one
I was hoping for in that conversation I
might have had a headline I'm trying to
recover from abysmal attendance a
headline helps you focus on the most
important idea in your message a
headlines easy to use as you leave today
you can practice headlines on your way
to lunch someone might ask you what are
you doing this weekend
practice headlines by starting with your
headline in your answer to your friend
you'll get used to beginning and
sometimes ending your messages with
headlines to keep you focused and
avoiding the sin of confusion lastly I
want to talk about why why why why is
one of the most important questions in
our communication far too often we
forget to share the reason why we're
communicating try using phrases such as
this matters because we care about this
because and that will help you focus on
why you are communicating practice this
today when you take out your computer
for your next email write down a quick
sentence of why you're writing that
email make sure you include it somewhere
in the body of your message with these
tools for concision you'll find that you
are able to structure and follow the
Cheshire cats advice to know where you
want to go now if structure is knowing
what you're going to say language is
more of how you're going to say it now
we're trying to aim for Less where it's
per sentence and the target is 17 so how
do we attempt to declutter our sentences
well we have the common I've got key
tips for you immediately picked after
your sentences one is avoiding jargon
second is avoiding phrases and third is
avoiding adverbs we hate adverbs
first avoiding dragon this is very
common at the GSB we love jurgis because
we think it makes a sound so smart but
honestly the only thing you ever use it
is if we get cold calls and strategy
class no idea what to do
one story actually I will share is when
I was interviewing for a startup I tried
to ask the founder how is your company
actually doing he pauses and says well
we ran into a negative capture position
for five consecutive years
and I thought to myself what does that
mean after five seconds are you guys
he's just trying to say we're back up
and for my management consulting friends
out there what does it actually mean to
boil the ocean I still don't know what
it means
second avoid phrases where know where it
is all you need a lot of words are sort
it's sort of like eating fresh and
Arbuckle or eating a bag of Doritos just
because you can just because there's
more there's a meaning it's a high
nutritional value probably not good for
you
even though it's tempting so one example
would be the current situation would
adversely impact our profits but all you
could just say is the simple red-hot
last point on adverbs our group hates
adverbs we spent 20 minutes in separate
praying for this presentation talking
about and ranting about adverts and
Stephen King agrees with us say the road
to hell is paved with adverbs he also
called it a dandelion there's nothing
wrong with a dandelion if it's just one
it looks pretty nice but if you let it
be it'll grow and fester and suddenly
all your sentences will be filled with
adverbs let's give a common example that
we here at the GSB normally say hi my
name is rich I'm currently an MBA
student at Stanford well obviously I am
currently an MBA
at Stanford so why not just take that
word out and keep it simple second
example I meet with my coach every day
when I was in high school telling me
rich let's start with the most basic
find the members but please remember
these three things avoid jargon avoid
phrases and avoid adverbs you can
immediately declutter your sentences so
now that we purged our sentences of
clutter we can focus on the verbs rich
has taught us that adjectives grow fat
verbs build muscle verbs energize and
tighten them each of your sentences when
you use a verb your sentences and your
ideas leap off the page and into your
audience's imagination but too often we
use weak limp verbs I'm gonna talk about
two common sins call them passive verbs
and hidden verbs now
passive verbs make your sentences long
confusing and boring
we collected 20 recent papers from
generous donors in this classroom and
here's what we found the passive voice
was deployed in one out of six sentences
written by this class now there's
nothing there's nothing technically
grammatically wrong with in a passive
voice we hear it all the time in
business here's one example but isn't
the second version so much shorter and
easier to understand so why do we use
the passive voice
well it sounds authoritative it can also
feel safer you don't have to assign
blame or responsibility but what it
really communicates is yanzhao and sin
number two cowardice
and so to title it also can be
ineffective if your audience is spending
time detangling your language that's
time they're not spending digesting your
message okay so to bring this together
when you use the passive voice you run
the risk that your message will be lost
under a pile of unclear wording your
tone can be interpreted as pompous and
you may be perceived as cowardly and
finally lives organisations and the
world may not be changed so be bold be
clear use active verbs the second thing
that we do to drain the energy out of
our sentences is use hidden verbs
what's a hidden verb a hidden verb is a
verb it's disguised as a noun
this is our last one no more passive
voice a hidden verb looks like a now
here's an example the responsibilities
of Austin's Department is the collection
of accounts if you strip away the
disguise here all we're saying is
Austin's department collects accounts in
each of our papers all 20 of them we
found hidden verbs they're everywhere
and so how do you find them two clues
first look for words that end in IOM
that's a good thing the second is look
for to be verbs any form of was is will
be when those are together there's a
good sense that there's a hidden verb
there and those add extra bulk to our
sentence they clutter your communication
and so when you change your nouns into
verbs your sentences become more
concrete more vigorous and that's what
we want to do for crisp clean focused
communication energize your verbs
so that's all there is
communicating concisely is difficult for
some of us more than others but there
are skills that each of us can practice
today
the second this presentation finishes
and we all get lunch all you have to do
is manage your mindsets
structure your thinking declutter your
language and energize your verbs as you
practice this you'll notice immediate
and dramatic improvement you'll also
gain the confidence to practice a fifth
skill which is often the most
challenging involve knowing when to stop
talking
[Music]